another covid19 testing site opening up  tomorrow this time at unlv's thomas and  max center that site is moving indoors  from the parking garage  it'll have different areas for those  with and without symptoms  appointments are encouraged but walk-up  testing is available  on a first come first serve basis it's  going to depend on the time of day  typically in the mornings we're a little  bit more busier than  in the afternoons and evenings however  want people with an appointment they  could be in and out as quick as 10  minutes the site is open tuesday through  saturday from 8 a.m to 4 p.m we do have  a link on our website at 8newsnow.com to  make an appointment  3